[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland ich bin Toni Heyer und ich
bin Mirko Kasimir Mirko sag mal was ist
eigentlich dein liebstes fest ich weiß
genau was du hören willst aber so leicht
Toni so leicht mache ich sie nicht mein
Lieblingsfest ist Weihnachten okay okay
du hast mich ertappt ich probiere es
anders was ist dein Lieblingsfest das
immer in der ersten Nacht vom 31 Oktober
auf den ersten november gefeiert wird
bei dem Kinder von Tür zur Tür gehen und
nach Süßigkeiten Fragen und bei dem
Kürbisse eine ganz große Rolle spielen
du meinst Halloween jetzt richtige
Antwort 100 Punkte und jetzt bitte
einmal raushauen was gefällt dir an
Halloween besonders gut du bist schon
eine ehrliche Antwort oder ja natürlich
gar nichts
du meinst natürlich dass es schön
gruselig ist richtig ja ich meine so so
richtig gruselig ist es ja gar nicht und
wenn es dann doch richtig gruselig ist
ja dann ist es auch nicht mehr schön so
wie Halloween 1974 in dir Park Text ist
meinst du das genau so wie Halloween
1974 in dir Park Texas nämlich richtig
gruselig und gar nicht schön wir
erzählen heute die Geschichte von
Candyman auch bekannt als the man who
killed Halloween wahrscheinlich habt ihr
alle schon mal Geschichten über
Rasierklingen oder Rattengift gehört die
fiese Erwachsene in Süßigkeiten
versteckt haben um sie Kindern zu geben
die so unvorsichtig waren an ihrer Tür
zu klingeln und triggert wie zu fordern
brauchen wir gar nicht lange drumherum
reden das meiste davon sind Mythen aber
okay da gab es diesen Typen einen
kalifornischen Zahnarzt der 1959
Süßigkeiten mit Abführmittel präparierte
üble Geschichte aber doch eine andere
Nummer als tödliche Gifte oder
Rasierklingen 30 Kinder wurden krank und
man sollte nicht vergessen dass das
nicht nur ein wirklich fieser Scherz war
sondern auch gefährlich hätte werden
können ein weiterer gut belegter Fall
stammt aus dem Jahr 1964 damals gab eine
grantige alte Dame in Long Island ein
Kinder die sie für zu alt hielt um nach
Süßigkeiten zu fragen ganz besondere
Päckchen heraus diese enthielten
Stahlwolle Hunde Knabbereien und
Ameisengift also erstmal ab wann ist man
denn zu alt für Süßigkeiten aber
abgesehen davon wirklich diese Nummer
allerdings hatte sie das Gift klar mit
dem Wort Gift gekennzeichnet keins der
Kinder kam auf die Idee das Zeug auch zu
essen so alt ist man für Süßigkeiten
wenn die Hose spannt
in den folgenden Jahrzehnten gab es
hunderte Berichte über vergiftete
Süßigkeiten oder die berühmten
Rasierklingen oder Nägel in Äpfeln und
Schokoriegeln kein einziger davon konnte
bestätigt werden sehr oft hatten Kinder
selbst ihre Süßigkeiten so präpariert
und ist dann gemeldet um andere zu
erschrecken um auf sich aufmerksam zu
machen oder einfach weil es eine so gute
Story war und diese Stories verbreiten
sich wie ein Lauffeuer sie ging so viral
wie es im analogen Zeitalter eben
möglich war ob sie stimmten das war
ebenfalls zweitrangig wenn überhaupt
an Halloween 1990 starb die
siebenjährige Arial cats in Santa Monica
nachdem sie in der Nachbarschaft
Süßigkeiten eingesammelt hatte die
Polizei reagierte sofort sie riegelte
ein ganzes Stadtviertel ab gab Warnungen
heraus und ging von Tür zu Tür um Eltern
zu warnen und Hinweise auf Gift zu
finden später stellte sich heraus dass
das kleine Mädchen an einem angeborenen
Herzfehler gestorben ist aber da war die
Geschichte von der vergifteten
siebenjährigen schon längst in aller
Munde richtig tragisch war das Schicksal
des fünfjährigen Kevin Thorsten der kurz
nach Halloween 1970 ins Koma fiel und
vier Tage später starb eine Untersuchung
fand Heroin auf sein Halloween
Süßigkeiten die Medien die treten durch
hier war der Beweis böse Menschen
töteten an Halloween unsere Kinder
der abschließende Polizeibericht bekam
dann nicht ganz so viel Aufmerksamkeit
die wahre Geschichte ein Onkel des
kleinen Kevin war Drogenabhängig als der
Junge bei ihm zu Besuch war fand er das
offenbar nicht besonders sichere Drogen
versteckt und vergiftete sich selbst
aber wie ist das Heroin auf die
Halloween Süßigkeiten gekommen das war
die Familie selbst um den Onkel zu
schützen präparierten sie die Trigger
treat Beute und die Medien und anfangs
auch die Polizei waren nur allzu bereit
die Story von einem Fremden der
vorsätzlich ein Kind mit Heroin
vergiftet hatte zu glauben also alles
nur Fake gibt es keine halloweenmodel
und keine vergifteten Süßigkeiten naja
also wir würden hier nicht drüber reden
wenn das alles nur ein Spaß wäre
Halloween 1974 eine regnerische Nacht in
Tierpark Texas was natürlich kein Kind
davon abhält um die Häuser zu ziehen zu
klingeln andere zu erschrecken sich
erschrecken zu lassen und Süßigkeiten
abzugreifen auch der achtjährige Tim hat
sie um Brian und seine fünfjährige
Schwester Elisabeth sind zusammen mit
ihrem Vater unterwegs
die Nachbar Jim Bates und sein kleiner
Sohn schließen sich der Gruppe an
es läuft gut bis sie an ein dunkles Haus
kommen offensichtlich ist niemand zu
Hause aber die Kinder wollen ihr Glück
versuchen und klopfen und klingen als
niemand öffnet rennen sie davon auf zum
nächsten Haus als Vater Ronald sie
wieder einholt hat er gute Nachrichten
es war doch jemand da erzählt er und
obwohl die Kinder schon weg waren hat er
eben ein paar Pixie Sticks mitgegeben
[Musik]
das sind so bunte längliche
Papiertütchen die sehen bisschen aus wie
ein langer Strohhalm und da drin ist
gefärbter aromatisierter Zucker
Ronald verteilt die Beute an die Kinder
es bleibt sogar noch so ein
zuckerröhrchen für ein anderes Kind
übrig dass sie auf dem Heimweg treffen
und das Ronald aus der Kirche kennt als
die O'Briens zu Hause ankommen darf sich
Timo sie etwas von den erbeuteten
Süßigkeiten aussuchen er wählt das Pixie
Sticks Röhrchen sein Vater muss ihn
helfen den Zucker herauszubekommen weil
der in dem Papier feststeckt
dann beschwert sich Timothy dass das
Pulver bitter schmeckt sein Vater holt
ihr meine Erfrischungsgetränk um es
herunter zu spülen und den geschmacklos
zu werden kurz danach beginnen die
Bauchschmerzen
Timothy rennt ins Bad erbricht sich
verfällt den Krämpfe
sein Vater ruft den Notarzt hält den
Jungen im Arm und merkt plötzlich wie
der Kleine körperschlaf wird keine
Stunde später ist Timothy O'Brien tot
der Staatsanwalt Mike hinten hat in
dieser Nacht Dienst in der
Polizeiinspektion von Harris County als
er einen Anruf der Polizei in pessedina
erhält die im mitteilt dass ein Kind
gestorben sei reagiert er sofort er ruft
einen Gerichtsmediziner an und bittet um
schnellen Rad
wonach hat er Atem des Kindes gerochen
fragt er hinten ruft im Leichenschauhaus
an und gibt die Frage weiter
da kommt Mandelgeruch aus dem Mund des
Kindes lautet die Antwort als ich hinten
erneut an den Gerichtsmediziner wendet
ist der sich sicher das ist ja Niete
[Musik]
das ist er der wahr gewordene Halloween
Albtraum mit cyanit versetzte
Süßigkeiten das ist echt der Horror in
einer Nacht in der man sich zwar
gruselig anzieht aber sich nicht
wirklich fürchten will
eine spätere Untersuchung wird ergeben
dass der kleine Timothy genug Gift
geschluckt hat um zwei oder drei
Erwachsene zu töten sofort schwärmen
Polizeibeamte in die Halloween-Nacht aus
um die anderen Pixie Sticks zu bergen
wenn man bedenkt wie ungehemmt viele
Kinder bei solchen Gelegenheiten naschen
grenzt es fast an ein Wunder aber die
anderen Tütchen sind noch voll und
ungeöffnet aber es ist eine verdammt
knappe Sache einer der jungen liegt
schlafend im Bett den Pixie Stick in der
Hand er wollte ihn essen hat ihn aber
nicht aufbekommen und ist darüber
eingeschlafen Moment nicht aufbekommen
also normalerweise ist das auch für
Kleinkinder kein Problem so ein Ding
aufzukriegen ja normalerweise schon aber
dieser Pixie Stick der ist nicht
original verschlossen sondern
zugetackert also eindeutig manipuliert
doch der Täter war etwas zu gründlich
und das hat das Leben des Kindes
gerettet der kleine Timothy bleibt das
einzige tragische Opfer des Candyman des
echten Halloween Killers
[Musik]
der Candyman muss ja eigentlich schnell
zu schnappen sein das ist nämlich genau
die Sache die ich immer so super
unglaubwürdig an diesen
vergiftungsgeschichten finde mal ehrlich
wer ist so blöd entschuldigung dass ich
so deutlich sage aber aus seinem eigenen
Haus heraus vergiftete Süßigkeiten zu
verteilen also
noch leichter kann man sicher nicht
schnappen lassen oder ja es sei denn
aber erzählen wir lieber erstmal weiter
Ronald Clark O'Brien führt die Polizei
zu jenem Haus das in der Halloween Nacht
in dunkel getaucht war er sagt er habe
nicht genau erkennen können wer ihm die
Süßigkeiten gegeben habe alles dunkel
wie gesagt und er sei ja auch schon auf
dem Sprung gewesen um seinen Kindern
hinterher zu rennen und naja eigentlich
habe er nur einen stark behaarten Arm
gesehen
ich finde ja übertriebenes Misstrauen
nicht richtig aber ich würde mir nichts
in den Mund stecken was mir ein
behaarter Arm aus einem Stock dunklen
hausreicht und ganz bestimmt würde ich
es nicht mein Kindern geben also wenn
ich welche hätte ja das könnte man so
unterschreiben jedenfalls timothies
Vater identifiziert das Haus doch als
Polizisten an die Tür Hämmern öffnet
niemand natürlich ist der Besitzer
schnell ermittelt ein Fluglotse am
William Hobby Airport in Houston kurz
darauf wird er auf seine Arbeitsstelle
vor den Augen seiner Kollegen verhaftet
schneller Erfolg der leider keiner ist
denn der Mann hat ein Alibi ja besser
gesagt er hat ungefähr 200 Alibis so
viele Leute können nämlich bezeugen dass
er in der Halloween Nacht gearbeitet hat
nur seine Frau und seine Tochter sind zu
Hause gewesen
sie haben früh das Licht ausgemacht sind
schlafen gegangen und haben nicht mehr
auf Klopfen reagiert weil ihnen die
Süßigkeiten ausgegangen waren Mutter und
Tochter
also da fragt man sich natürlich sofort
wem von den beiden bitte der stark
behaarte Arm gehört haben soll oder ob
noch jemand mit dem Haus war oder ob
vielleicht alles ganz anders war und das
scheint plötzlich gar nicht mehr so
abwegig als ein Versicherungsunternehmen
sich bei der Polizei meldet es stellt
sich heraus dass Ronald O'Brien mehrere
Lebensversicherungen auf seinen Sohn und
seine Tochter abgeschlossen hat
die letzte erst einen Monat vor
Halloween und am Tag danach gegen 9 Uhr
am Morgen nach Halloween gut 12 Stunden
nach dem Tod seines Sohnes der rief er
bei der Versicherung an um das Geld
einzufordern und jetzt klopft die
Polizei wieder an eine Haustür an die
von Ronald O'Brien dem trauernden Vater
dem nach dem Tod seines Sohnes nichts
besseres einfällt als so schnell wie
möglich die Versicherung zu kassieren
sie durchsuchen das Haus und finden eine
Schere an der Plastikreste kleben wie
man sie auch an den vergifteten
Süßigkeiten gefunden hat Ronald O'Brien
wird verhaftet und der Verdacht gegen
ihn wird immer stärker Zeugen erinnern
sich dass er in einem Volkshochschulkurs
seltsame Fragen stellte unter anderem
was ist tödlicher Zyankali oder ein
anderes Gift
ein Mitarbeiter eines Chemieunternehmens
erinnert sich an einen Mann dessen
Beschreibung auf Ronald O'Brien passt
und der wohl versucht hat bei ihm zu
Ernie zu kaufen und nicht zuletzt ist da
die Tatsache dass O'Brien hoffnungslos
verschuldet ist und das Geld aus den
versicherungspolizen verdammt dringend
braucht am 5 mai 1975 beginnt in Houston
der Prozess gegen Ronald O'Brien er ist
angeklagt wegen Mordes an seinem Sohn
und vierfachen versuchten Mordes er habe
nicht nur versucht seine eigenen Kinder
umzubringen sondern auch die Kinder
anderer Familien nur um von sich als
Täter abzulenken
zahlreiche Zeugen treten auf sie
sprechen von einem merkwürdigen
Verhalten auf der Beerdigung seines
Sohnes als ihm die Aussicht auf einen
Urlaub den er von dem Geld der
Versicherung bezahlen wollte wichtiger
zu sein schien als sein verstorbenes
Kind
mehrere bekannte berichten dass er in
den Wochen vor Halloween immer wieder
ein merkwürdiges Interesse an Cyanid
gezeigt hatte und seine Frau gibt an
dass sich der kleine timelphi den Pixie
Stick keineswegs selbst ausgesucht hat
sondern dass sein Vater ihn im
regelrecht aufgedrängt habe Ronald
O'Brien streitet alle Vorwürfe ab die
Verteidigung stützt sich ganz auf die
allseits bekannten aber völlig
unbegründeten Geschichten von verrückten
giftmischern die an Halloween wahllos
morgen ein solcher müsste sich in das
Haus des Fluglotsen geschlichen haben um
seine finstere Tat zu begehen die
Schauergeschichten nutzen überhaupt gar
nichts
am dritten juni 1975 befindet in die
Jury nach kurzer Beratung für schuldig
er wird zum Tode verurteilt
am 31 März stirbt Ronald O'Brien durch
Gift das ihm von Justizbeamten
initiierte
[Musik]
Mirko ich muss sagen ich habe mich
vorher schon kurz gewundert als wir
darüber gesprochen haben dass sie an
diesem dunklen Haus bei dem niemand
aufmacht warten und die Kinder gehen vor
und er bleibt da noch ein bisschen
länger stehen bis ihm jemand Süßigkeiten
daraus reicht das fand ich ehrlich
gesagt schon ein bisschen off also
seltsam weil er wird doch meine Kinder
dann nicht vor sein lassen und bleibt
bei einem Haus von dem ich ausgeht dass
da jemand da ist noch weiter stehen oder
ja ich denke Kinder sind natürlich auch
bisschen Ahnung muss los ne die vermuten
hier auch nichts Böses in dieser
Geschichte schon gar nicht wenn die
Eltern mit dabei sind oder der Vater mit
dabei ist das finde ich auch ganz krass
also das muss ich sagen erstmal
furchtbar dass er sein eigenes Kind
sozusagen
opfert und man Geld zu kommen aber dann
eben auch noch diese andere Ebene das
Vertrauen auszunutzen seine eigenen
Kinder man erwartet ja nicht dass die
eigenen Eltern die dich ja eigentlich
beschützen mit ihrem Leben die aber
deins nehmen
davon damit rechnest du ja nicht als
Kind auch erst schon gar nicht dass ihr
irgendjemand was Böses will und ich
finde ganz furchtbar dass er ganz ganz
ganz vielen Kindern und auch seine
eigenen Familie so ein schönes Fest was
eigentlich zelebriert wird was Freude
bringen soll was Spaß machen soll
wirklich für immer versaut hat für die
betroffenen Familien wird Halloween
natürlich für immer und ewig verdorben
sein das ist ja nur absolut verständlich
für den Rest der Welt ja
geht es so weiter wie bisher dafür
vergessen wir Menschen einfach viel zu
schnell was einen schlimmen Dingen in
der Welt passiert
und bei all dem denke ich das auch
hauptsächlich so die Eltern die
Bedenkenträger sind die sich dann mit
diesen horror stories beschäftigen und
die Kinder nach wie vor sehr unbedarf
daran gehen völlig klar und
normalerweise wenn die Kinder sich in
der bekannten Nachbarschaft bewegen du
kennst deine Nachbarn und lässt dir
jetzt auch nicht durch die ganze Stadt
ziehen dann
sollte da auch an sich nichts passieren
ausgeschlossen dass nie etwas ja und so
ein gewisses Risiko gibt's immer also
das bringt einfach das Leben mit sich
auch wenn das eine wirklich tragische
Geschichte ist und
das mit Sicherheit niemand zu erwartet
hätte aber
er hat halt dieses Event ausgenutzt um
seine furchtbare Tat umzusetzen weil er
dachte er kommt damit davon aber so war
es ja zum Glück nicht ja so also von
daher würde ich jetzt nicht sagen dass
Halloween
ein Fest mit großem Gefahrenpotenzial
ist das sicherlich nicht höchstens für
die für die Zähne ja für Karies dann
wieder viel mehr Besuche bei dem beim
Zahnarzt anstehen genau da hast du
absolut Recht
also man auch wenn diese Geschichte
natürlich sehr grausam ist ist dieses
Fazit was wir hier gerade ziehen so ganz
kleines minimales Augenzwinkern und
damit sind wir am Ende der heutigen
Episode angekommen wir danken Euch ganz
herzlich dass ihr wieder mit dabei wart
und freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten Mal einschaltet eure Toni und
eure Mirko
bei der Recherche haben wir Artikel von
cbc.com Slate weiß und der
englischsprachigen Wikipedia sowie eine
Episode der Halloween poisoner des
Podcasts paschenary Tales with time Ford
verwendet